over the last century the beauty
industry has spent an incalculable
amount of money to create the standard
of what beauty is
and for those who don't measure up well
there's always hope in a jar
the copywriters are really tapping into
people's emotions and most often
people's insecurities
think how much dust and dirt settle on
your skin
a clean skin is a healthy skin one day
you realize you're not going to be 21
forever yet you always want to look your
best
but today's generation of consumers are
rejecting unrealistic and narrow images
of beauty with that stance comes a
similar expectation of the product
newer companies like rihanna's fenty
beauty are redefining the cosmetic and
fashion industries with offerings and
advertising revolving around needs that
have historically been ignored by large
multinational brands
the stakes of turning a blind eye are
costlier now and with over 300 billion
in black dollars up for grabs those
legacy corporations won in
now
brands are starting to recognize
that
they have to get on board with the
inclusive beauty movement or get left
behind
but can the beauty industry become a
true force for body positivity and
inclusion beyond the one-off campaign
[Music]
there are a handful of large
multinational cosmetic companies in the
world many of which have dominated the
industry over the past century
historically they have operated with an
impunity of sorts their only competition
is with each other while new companies
posing any threat were kept on the
fringe or acquired
but in the last few years smaller
startups have been slowly eating into
their share of the cosmetics market
none more well known than rihanna's
fenty beauty
here we are with the creator of fenty
beauty rihanna we're going to show you
how to get the fenty face
i think that
we can't underestimate the impact that
fenty had
on the industry
so fenty is a brand that was founded by
rihanna robin fenty
a musician with a huge platform
but also
a very strong connection
with
the black community
and especially the younger generation
my students my undergraduate students
love fenty they love rihanna they all
want to write their research paper on
rihanna
and the business that she's built
launched in september of 2017 fenty
reportedly made 100 million in sales in
just 40 days
today estimates put the fenty brand at
around four billion dollars
when fenty came out it was a game
changer i think in the cosmetics
industry in so many ways
people were very excited that she was
making something for us you know we felt
like of course this black woman is going
to make something that works for many of
us and she did
fenty beauty success is rooted in
products that are made for the most
underrepresented groups and showcasing
them through ads that reflect their
lives
fenty isn't the first brand to create
products that cater to women of color
but it came at a time when consumers
expectations of beauty were changing
fenty didn't just meet overlooked needs
it sent a message to those century-old
companies in doing so
either adapt with the times or watch
customers go elsewhere
i started researching the advertising
industry in the early 20th century and
this is when we start to see the
emergence of a modern
advertising
industry
another shift that we see happening in
the early 20th century that is so
important to this story of advertising
is a shift from reason why advertising
copy that is tapping into people's
insecurities
one campaign that i can think of is ad
copy that says will your husband love
you in 20 years
so
if you're not taking care of your skin
as time goes by
then your skin is going to show sign of
aging
so that taps into you know a fear of
losing your husband perhaps to a younger
woman
and of course you know in business if
something is working then that strategy
is going to continue
anyone who's ever glanced at a magazine
over the last century could see those
inner workings at play
that kind of psychological appeal would
only continue
and by the age of photoshop not only was
the image of beauty fairly narrow it was
at times impossible
we see
a continuation of the emotional appeal
up until
maybe 2004 you know when dove introduced
its real beauty campaign and
really got a lot of attention for a
different kind of appeal to women become
part of dove's largest living ad
campaign for real women by real women
just like you and me and me and me the
real beauty campaign was
one of the first ones i think to
put a little more politics into
this variety of representation and i
think it was a version of body
positivity in the sense of accepting a
wider variety of bodies not just super
thin white feminine bodies
particularly in terms of cosmetic
advertising which tends to focus on
women but at the same time it's a
company so they're trying to sell
something they're trying to sell an idea
that idea of real beauty did well for
dove and parent company unilever
the campaign received many awards and
still garners media attention and
acclaim to this day he has know dove
you know they have a lot of ads about
positive body image in three years the
company increased sales from two to four
billion dollars
and so i think the success of that
campaign of people thinking yeah dove
cares about me and how i feel about my
body that other companies were like okay
yeah we want to make you think that too
because
we got to sell this thing to you
but outside of the ad campaign itself
parent corporations like unilever have
had issues embodying the ethos of real
beauty
at the same time dove was promoting body
inclusion unilever's indian subsidiary
hindustan unilever was profiting from
sales of its fair and lovely skin
whitening product including advertising
which suggested whitening your skin
would lead to better employment
opportunities
the brand makes around 500 million in
revenue for unilever each year
and while companies like johnson and
johnson have announced plans to stop
making skin lightening products
hindustan unilever has opted to just
change the name to glow and lovely
in a statement the company said we
recognize that the use of the words fair
white and light suggests the singular
ideal of beauty that we don't think is
right and we want to address this
the name change falls short of demands
from activists to stop selling skin
whitening creams entirely because they
imply darker skin is undesirable
i think campaigns are just the tip of
the iceberg and can be kind of a
band-aid and changing fare to glow
doesn't really address
the the problems with colorism and that
i think is where
companies fall short is that they want
this visual representation of difference
without actually putting the politics
behind it to understand how are we
addressing the root causes of the lack
of diversity in the first place how are
we attending to racism and anti-fatness
within the cosmetic industry within the
fashion industry
even when companies approach advertising
with diversity in mind the products they
offer haven't necessarily reflected that
foundation colors cater more often to
lighter skin colors even today if you go
into your local pharmacy there are many
shades for lighter skin but only a few
for darker skin tones
the average range of foundation shades
in a major company
might be
10
15 you know depending on the brand
what a lot of women had to do was start
mixing
their own
foundations they had to become
chemists in order to get the foundation
color that they needed for their skin
tone this is what everything looks like
in my bowl including the powder okay so
there's a little bit of something in
there for everybody i remember when i
finally was allowed to wear makeup going
to the drugstore and scanning the aisles
and finding that you know of the one
long aisle of makeup there was this tiny
little section not even a full section
that was meant for me as a black woman
and that can make you feel small
it can make you feel neglected but
certainly how it made me feel it made me
feel like oh okay
my beauty matters this much in the world
of beauty mine matters this much and i i
just don't think anyone should ever have
to feel that way but it is something i
think a lot of people will tell you they
have felt before
this is kj miller the co-founder and ceo
of mented cosmetics founded in january
of 2017 with the goal to bring products
to people of all skin tones
we decided to start with lipstick nude
lipstick because that's what we couldn't
find and so we sat down and
watched youtube videos on how to make
your own lipstick and bought all of the
necessary ingredients the oil the wax
the colorants the micas and started
making the lipsticks in our homes
and i created that shade it's called
minted number five the first shade that
we made and it still today almost five
years later is one of our top sellers
we've made millions of dollars in that
sku and it was the first shade i made
and you know what i think that showcases
is that it's not rocket science creating
products that work for deeper skin tones
but you have to want to do it you have
to put effort into it
and in the last five years many other
indie cosmetic brands like hyper skin
beauty stat bevel and more have also
popped up to fill this void in the
market
and just a few months after meant it
launched so did fenty beauty
[Music]
fenty started out with 40 shades
now fenty has 50 shades of foundation
they're really addressing the needs of a
wide range of consumers
my vibe for summer is
more
is more it was super exciting to see
that possibility and see all the ads
that they put out with so many women
dark skinned women wearing makeup that
worked for them
fenty is a real example of how you can
appeal to a really large audience but
still center the most marginalized
people and we see that also in the fenty
savage lingerie brand as well the
centering of larger bodies and of people
of color
and while fenty and companies like
mented center some of the least
represented groups in their advertising
their product can appeal to everyone if
you think about the biggest brands the
most successful consumer brands the
nikes of the world they have a target
right nike's target
audience is an athlete but millions of
non-athletes wear nike
why because they make a great
high-performance product and i think
it's the same here
yes my target is people of color
but because i'm targeting them and
giving them deeply pigmented high
quality products that attracts a lot of
different people
i would say quite a few of the larger
beauty companies
then jumped on the bandwagon after fenty
i mean that's part of the fenty effect
that companies were following
fenty's lead
only a year after fenty's launch
covergirl maybelline and dior all
released more inclusive foundation
shades and there are indications in the
research involved in claims testing that
suggest more are on the way
so historically a lot of these claims
test have only looked at white skin
and now we're seeing more and more
companies ask for testing
that looks at a wider range of skin
tones
it appears that relatively recently
there's been a backlog
in testing
because so many more companies are
asking for tests
that consider a much wider range of skin
tones
even though large companies are recently
pivoting to create products to compete
in this space or acquire successful
startups
maintaining that authenticity in both
the product and advertising will be key
consumers nowadays especially
the younger generation of consumers
they're very savvy
so i think that
unless a message is authentic unless it
feels authentic to the consumer the
consumer is not going to waste
his or her time with that particular
brand
ultimately i support consumers having
more choice but i do think consumers are
going to
continue to
themselves you know where do i want to
spend my money is it with a brand that
has since launched been focusing on me
and celebrating me and telling me that i
matter or is it with a brand that had
the last 50 years
to tell me i matter but sort of got on
board in 2019
you know and it's going to be a
consumer's choice
for brands who had a hand in helping to
narrow down the image of beauty
expanding it now means that they must
also look at themselves
part of the thing that i think needs to
change is that it can't just be we put
two black people in an ad and we've got
four skin tones now for you but it also
means that we're going to hire more
people of color we're going to hire more
queer folks so that from the start
we've got people who are providing their
perspectives connected to their
communities and bringing that knowledge
in at every level that is incorporated
throughout and not just about tokenism
in order to create sales but actually
transforming a company
on the next episode of business of
beauty
lighter skin has long been associated
with power and privilege and the beauty
industry has been profiting selling skin
lightening creams and soaps which are
popular around the world but now some
people are going even further
the patients look forward to have a much
fairer or a wider skin and they could go
to any length to achieve that
you